naftalí bennett es un multimillonario
antes emprendedor en tecnología hijo de
padres nacidos en eeuu el antiguo
comandante de las fuerzas especiales
vendió su startup por 145 millones de
dólares en 2005 y se adentró en la
política al año siguiente
en su paso por el likud fue el jefe de
gabinete de benjamín netanyahu hasta
2008 en 2012 benet pasó a liderar el
partido nacionalista casa judía y desde
entonces no ha ocultado su deseo por
convertirse en el nuevo líder de la
derecha israelí
a pesar de su tensa relación con
netanyahu fue ministro de defensa
educación y economía en varios de sus
gobiernos
a la cabeza de yamina a una alianza de
derechas
bennett tiene una postura más liberal en
los derechos del sbt y el secularismo
que algunos de sus antiguos aliados
aboga por liberalizar la economía pero
su defensa de expandir las colonias
judías en territorio palestino y anexar
cisjordania son el centro de su discurso
oliván creo que soy el único nuestro
partido es el único en el estrado que se
opone a fundar un estado palestino en la
tierra de israel entre el jordán y el
mediterráneo
ranjan pero con la nueva coalición del
cambio se espera que bennett no
implemente toda su agenda política al
menos por ahora
[Aplausos]